hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to I remember the rain now
as far as I can tell it's a very serious
game that covers possibly a serious
subject but in fact I actually don't
know anything about it because I didn't
have a chance to look up a lot of
research on it I just saw that it looked
very somber so be warned cuz this is
gonna be adventure for the both of us
and I really don't know what to expect
that and wait that night
oh I was supposed to oh I was forced
person thing I apologize bye-bye birdies
oh this looks fun
I'm glad the rain is putting me in a
very film noir esque mood so what
horrible things
oh-ho I'm playing now okay funny the
things you remember thousands of tiny
races against my skin
oh yes very film noir Quebec oh I wonder
what the ambulance is gonna be for I'm
sure it's going which they don't hit
oh okay uh playing out the situations
the things I could have said how I could
have changed
I've been waiting here for days what
have you been waiting for a friend okay
cool
that doctor is wise wise man thanks lady
glad to know you care what what is this
is gonna be the game now I'm gonna be
wandering around the waiting room of a
hospital doc you got blood on your coat
oh oh man it's nothing
ah but I wanted to do it 5:30 in the
morning and lack of sleep hmm oh boy oh
boy
okay bye I didn't want to talk to you
anyway so long and good night what is
that the end of the game
so what you're gonna leave me on so you
can leave me mostly drained on why does
it look like a chapel door oh because it
is a chapel door oh wait is oh god what
is that did you get that out of a
fortune cookie thanks lady Oh guys it's
gonna be cliched quotes isn't it yes
that's the question everybody asks how
give you some someone's entire life in a
single day so many words I wanted to say
I spoke to them
I said to you
what was the point
why I I wonder I really wonder if the
developer experience real loss and just
made this into a game based on
experiences in their own life but why
wait there's more wait hang on I press I
press the stop recording button what is
this what is this what's going on here
shall I turn on the tube why I'm quiet
why am I still this hello wait a minute
ssam a right there what's going on
oh no no hope ah no why do you have got
this good but I can't even move ah odd
why is this part of this why is this
part of this why good good
you don't have to die to be dead
well that's cheerful what is the point
of that oh man this is like oh we're not
done yet
I thought the rollercoaster of emotions
was over and then I had to experience
this baloney or not baloney it's you
know man I said an outro already
oh man oh man man oh man what the hell's
up man
but it was huge
like this
and this banner zips up blueberry pop ow
why is this something that I have to go
through no I don't want you guys to
think that I don't mind going through
these emotional games but it's just like
it's late it's like I don't know if I'll
include the outro that I did already
when I saw the VN screen oh no what was
that well you guys okay you remember the
rain okay so now I'm confused because I
don't like I understand like well okay
what I'll include like a little bit of
what I said before but it's like it's
like these little bite-sized happy fun
sized versions of sad it's like these
games are emotional experiences I talked
a little about art but I'm so
sleep-deprived that it's just like I
can't coordinate thoughts out of my
brain but I guess these games are
important in terms of like an artistic
expression because I was wondering if if
the creator of this game Jordan Brown
like had any experience in their life
that was like this and they could only
represent that through a game or
something that they could create to try
to channel their emotions and their
feelings into something or maybe not
maybe they just wanted to make a game
that made people feel and there's
nothing wrong with that either but it's
just like I don't know what to take away
from this there's no learning experience
for me it's just like you get to see me
be exposed to it which is good in its
own right I guess some people want to
see that and I played because it was
suggested in his this is what it is so
thank you everybody so much for watching
thank you guys for being here and I
guess the lesson to take away from all
this is just you know tell the ones you
care about that you care because the
problem and the problem with things like
this is that some things get left
unspoken and you never know you never
know when the thing you care about will
be taken away from you whether it's your
control or not so remind the people
around you that they matter and it's
more importantly than I think that they
matter to you and you know maybe you'll
hear from someone that you matter to
them too and that'll come right when you
need it most
so just remember from me
youyou guys matter incredibly and I love
you guys lots so thank you everybody so
much for watching and as always I will
see you in the next video bye bye
about me something's gonna happen
who is that a person I thought it was
come back here I got some questions for
you tick three two oh four eight six
three I don't know what that mean